hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
what's an imperative if something is in
the imperative what is that your Spanish
class yeah very good it's a command so I
am wearing a tie that's indicative we
would say in English
wear a tie that's a command right if
you're going to go to a job interview
you should wear a tie Kant would say
that's also an imperative tale so really
anything that's going to have lot or
should will be some kind of imperative
some kind of telling you what to do and
you've been given a lot of imperatives
all right I still get them all the time
and you'll get them the rest of your
life the IRS is going to tell you you
should pay this amount of taxes if you
don't that will penalize you you know a
game the cop is going to tell you to go
that way rather than go that way the
ticket people are going to tell you come
up let me frisk you
you get that sort of thing all the time
but you get yourself imperatives to them
sure do you ever tell yourself you
should do something you haven't doing
you tell yourself you should know so do
you not guess if you do that here you're
pretty well a lot provided you've got
the right imperatives if you don't then
you're pretty much like most people you
know we're not we're not perfectly
constant conferencing so now how can we
think of imperative concepts we have to
think about them if we won't understand
moral life we have to understand it in
terms of imperative and that's the kind
of beings in again we're rational beings
right we can reason that's why we can't
have a pair of us you can get the dog in
here that you can say sit you know and
then you give it a cookie and the dog
after a while figures out that if it
keeps doing that it's gonna keep getting
cookies and after a while they don't
have to get the cookies anymore but you
you know you're different than the dog
the dog never actually tells itself I
should sit now because I would like a
cookie it just sort of docile alright
Khan says you're unique because as a
rational being you can give loss to
yourself which means you can tell
yourself so what you know think about
today all of you are here it's 3:45 on a
Tuesday afternoon kind of dreary you
could be in bed right now or you could
be watching TV maybe doing both or you
could be off in the library reading
about something that you're more
interested in you know doing work for
other classes
you actually made yourself coming back
you told yourself this is a good thing
to do even if you don't you know weren't
completely convinced that it was a great
idea
like that Lee said well I should do it
I'm willing to bet then at this point in
the semester some of you had some second
thoughts about all right I don't know
you know I got so many absences I can
take maybe this would be a good day for
a sick day you know we all do that sort
of thing but you you gave yourself an
imperative it's all your stuff this is
the right thing to do now the question
then that you can ask is well why yeah
there's a lot of ways that you can
arrange this or think about this cop
breaks them down into three basic groups
and before you guys then breaks them
into categorical imperatives and
hypothetical imperatives so these are
some some technical terms that we want
to sort of get down before we delve into
it and a lot of the technical terms when
it comes to this we can probably set
aside but these two are absolutely
essential so hypothetical I think you
guys are more familiar with that if you
say if somebody asks you something and
you say hypothetically yes you're not
really committing yourself right are you
going to go to the party next Friday
hypothetically and now you notice I've
got this gift that right well if these
things happen or if these conditions
hold then yes I'll go there do you need
to wear a tie to wear ties to alright
but let's say it's a tight car it says
there write out the invitation everyone
must wear a tie so you say well if I
want to go to that party got to get
myself a tie and I've got to actually
put it up maybe I'll take it off halfway
through or so once I get in the door but
and I wear the tie or you could ask
yourself if I'm going to teach a class
you could ask yourself a question like
if I'm going to teach you that should I
wear attire you know my ask my wife is
these these sort of questions not about
class you know places we're gonna go
what kind of what should I wear is it
okay to wear jeans so I have to wear
dress shoes do I need to wear a tie you
know it was a big adjustment for me
come here and find out that you know you
can go just about anywhere you want so
long as you've got a pair of nice jeans
on and you know decent shoes you can
just wear like a t-shirt and then a
sports jacket and everybody thinks
that's that's a okay because other
places I've lived you know you look
ridiculous but around here you know
apparently that's the hip thing to do if
you're an academic and so you can you
know arrange those sort of things in
terms of hypotheticals well if you're in
this environment then you should wear
this none of you are wearing ties today
right or you know fancy power suits or
whatever so many a wing sweats somebody
wearing the mustard casuals supposed to
be a little bit more dressy you know I
guess it's a sweater right something
like that you know you can ask yourself
is this the existent thing to wear for
the classroom you know well you know
what does it depend on do you need to
wear a tie in order to learn to ethics I
don't think so you need to dress up for
it
probably not I didn't dress up when I
learned it early dress started dressing
up when I started teaching it you know
so you know there's all these conditions
that you can ask about their
hypothetical they don't hold in every
single case and comp breaks those down
into two different types so first he
talks about the actions that we do for
the sake of some other goal he talks
about a doctor right doctors have to
know a lot of different things
some of you are
one of you is pretty mad something along
those lines really anything that you
guys are studying you have to know a lot
of things in your major you started that
started to dawn on you by now right this
part of junior year when now you're
taking a lot of major classes like a lot
of work involved in this well because
you're learning your skill your learning
your trade and just so happens that a
lot of your trades have been around for
hundreds of years so people you know a
little bit about that sort of sort of
thing but it's all manners you know
doing doing something in order to bring
about some other yourself so if you're a
doctor what's your goal in general yeah
oh yeah yeah you can also say to make
money or things like that but what is it
what is it characteristic about a doctor
what do they do right so they're they're
part of what we call the caring
professions or there's actually a fancy
word for it I'm not sure if I can even
pronounce it right thee a little a
little sorry no I can't even pronounce
it comes with a little Greek word for
for pity to take pity on other people
nurses fit in there EMTs fit in there if
you're a doctor why do you do the things
that you do to try to bring about this
end healing me then you might have other
let's do like have your own practice
some day those who are going to become
teachers what's what's your product
what's your your racket about
teach other kids yeah some knowledge
should actually occur some learning the
kid should leave your classroom at the
end of the semester better informed than
they were before if you want that to
happen are there things that you should
do like what let's take the teacher
example what should you do yeah okay
that's pretty high level stuff right
there
that's that's better than like showing
up making sure you have a list of land
differentiate the classroom so that you
attend to the needs of all the different
types of learners some people are more
tactile some people are more connected
some people are charts yeah I mean if
you're doing that you're probably doing
a lot of other things a lot of whaitiri
because if you want to do that you can
say well what do you have to do in order
to do that you take that as it's a petty
as an end how many other things you have
to do along the way quite a few you
actually have to know about learning
styles right you have to have some
proficiency now what if your car
mechanic do you need to care about
learning styles or differentiating your
maybe your customers reading till
ripping the sides
no you don't dude you're right you don't
not all car mechanics actually explain
you feel like you can tell them exactly
what's wrong yeah that's just like
immediately I don't know anything like
you should be like well this was like
it's what's tight like I mean it's not
yeah he's going to a death so imagine
imagine the human body near car is like
this
your car's liver is bad yeah yeah you
know it's interesting this is just a
total side note but in every profession
some of the best people in the
profession are good teachers so a good
car mechanic actually teaches got a
friend is a Salesman now he sells good
products it helps if you're gonna solve
a good product so you don't rely to
people and all that but he sees his job
not so much as doing sales as educating
his customers and helping them reason
out what they want to buy yeah and you
see that a lot of different fields you
know it's kind of funny I knew a police
officer once who talked about himself
being a Salesman and he talked about his
job selling people jail terms because he
was an interrogator I need to talk to
them and get them to sort of reveal
information start talking
they reveal a lot of stuff he was also
really good at that sort of educating
people and he kind of he'd educate
people after he after he got their
confession about now here's how the
process is great to work now they
understood it very well but now all
these are just merely hypothetical you
know if you want to do this sort of
thing that you should do this then this
should be the case so if you're gonna be
a teacher then yeah you should do all
these things that's good for you to do
because it leads to this end if you're
gonna be a car mechanic maybe you have a
lot of other hats if you're going to be
a police officer you have other heads
right if you're gonna wash chalkboards
for a living if there was such a job
then you have a much more restricted set
of hands that yeah
now the problem with trying to get
morality on this is that there's always
the questionable what if you don't want
those ends what if it doesn't apply to
you any of the shoulds that you can get
from what he's going rules of skill
they're merely hypothetical they're not
actually applying to everybody across
the board so they may you know what
remember when we talked about duties
coming out of roles contas rejecting
that sort of thing let's go a little bit
higher now and thinking about this so
there is something that we all do want
happiness kind of things he understands
them a little bit differently than
Aristotle did or Milton he understands
happiness is being the sanity calls it
the satisfaction of all your
inclinations and desires and we talked
about this a little bit it's not the
same for for you necessarily as it is
for me and nor is it the same for you as
the person sitting next to you we have
different inclinations and desires but
there are some that we tend to share in
common right what are some really basic
things that I think we can say we all do
want part of their life
any of you want to be totally alone
no friends no family that's your ideal
of you know I mean if you have a huge
family there may be some times where
you're like man I'd like to get away
from these people for a while that's
just for a while that's not forever
right there's the difference between
going off and being alone and being
totally without people being lonely
maybe that's part of you know what we
want to seek out
it's a somebody like Aristotle or Anil
would say well there are other things
you need a certain amount of well don't
you any of you want to be bottoms on the
street no I think we can agree we need a
certain amount of wealth certain amount
of maybe property or opportunities or
things like that
but it's gonna be a bit different for
each of us is enough and when it comes
to our tastes certainly anything are we
similar to each other may have something
in common
we're gonna be some movies we agree on
but some of us may like movies more some
of us may not care about movies some of
us may only watch this genre same thing
with music same thing with TV shows same
thing with do you go and watch plays or
not what sports do you like pick any of
these sort of things that we consume and
happiness starts to look like something
quite varied are you even sure what all
your desires and inclinations are at
this point context that is pretty hard
to figure out exactly what you want so
that's going to be a problem I mean
there are some things you can figure out
that you should do where you ought to do
they're what we call councils of
prudence meaning that it's prudent it's
likely to lead you to happiness if you
do those sort of things but you're not
quite sure what he happiness looks like
right and so he talks about this is a
really nice passage he says if it were
only easy to give a definite conception
of happiness the imperatives of prudence
would correspond exactly with those of
skill for in this case as in that it
could be set whippoorwills the yin wills
also the indispensable means but
unfortunately the notion of happiness is
so indefinite that although every person
wishes to attain it each one of you is
motivated by the desire for happiness
but you're not quite sure what that is
you have some ideas and you have some
ideas of what's going to make you
unhappy but this is a bad thing to say
but you don't even know the things that
are gonna make you unhappy five years
from now because you know they're not
even really on your horizon yet so he
says the reason of this is the elements
which belong to the notion of happiness
are all together empirical the things in
this world things that we experience
when they say empirical that means that
we experience it and they have to be
borrowed for experience so what are some
examples he says well do you will riches
to be you know not just financially
independent but to have a lot of money
well is that going to necessarily make
you happy that might bring about anxiety
and envy you don't want that do you
what about knowledge in discernment I
think all of you are after knowledge
otherwise you wouldn't be here in
college but that might only improve Lee
says proved to be only in eyes so much
the sharper to show him so much more
than fearfully the evils that are now
concealed from them think about some of
the classes that you took that opened
your eyes and things
afterwards you were a little bit
depressed jaboney classes like that so
far like maybe a psychology class or an
economics class or you know all sorts of
things thank you you know really doing
well before and that you take a class me
like oh yeah
according to Plato my life is
meaningless I better figure out what to
do
well you know knowledge doesn't always
bring me happiness we think it might but
doesn't how is what about a long life it
could be a long bad life couldn't it and
he goes on and on with this and he says
so these sorts of things these merely
experiential principles are not actually
going to be enough to orient us for
morality they do tell us what's good for
us in a sense but they don't tell us
what's morally good if we want what's
more really good we have to turn to
categorical imperatives so now here's
again a term that you probably don't use
very much if you're being categorical
with somebody you're saying this holds
absolutely
there's no qualifications there's no
exemptions or exceptions to the rule
you're saying this applies to everyone
so if I say it's a categorical rule that
all students must hand in the final exam
I'm saying it applies to all of it no no
no special dispensations from it or
anything like that so when you're when
you're issuing a categorical statement
or command or imperative you're saying
it holds universally if that helps you
to say Universal instead of categorical
that I think that would be perfectly
fine to them to change the word for them
now in categorical imperative doesn't
tell you to do any action for the sake
of some other thing like you want to
make your patient better you should do
this because you know it could be you
don't want to make your patient better
maybe you want to make your patient
worse in that case that's not going to
hold
a categorical imperative is going to
hold in every case so I suppose if you
were you know dealing with doctors you
could say well you want to always make
your patient better and you know for
somebody to ask well why should I make
my patient better maybe it's not going
to make me you know some money or you
know expand my practice or give me the
grant that I want you'd be kind of
missing the point you'd be saying I'm
treating it like a hypothetical when
it's really a categorical command you
know I think that that in the
Hippocratic oath for doctors you guys
are all familiar with this right what's
what's sort of the one big assumption
for them don't do harm yeah first I
thought you said do ya do know her right
that's a categorical statement it's not
saying do no harm unless it's one of
those kind of situations where you think
it might be justified or do no harm
because that way you'll become rich or
do no harm because it'll make you feel
like a good person it's just that do no
harm that's what makes it categorical
right and if you start introducing other
things that loses that status as soon as
you start saying what would be another
example let's take mine for example if
you say to somebody when they're a kid
don't lie it's wrong for you to lie
count does it by the way thing it's
always wrong to lie immediately the kid
asks one right that's what kids do those
are either going to be teachers all the
time now if you actually answer that cut
it says and you're not just saying look
it's wrong and I want you to understand
that it's wrong but you say something
like well if you lie people are gonna
like you count things that you're
actually taking the kid in the wrong
direction morality has to do
with this stuff up here not with this
stuff down here something I'll think
about this somebody like middle would
say well it's okay to lie in certain
circumstances if it's going to promote
the greatest happiness right God would
say you can never lie it's always going
to be wrong that's what it means for a
statement to be you know a command to be
categorical so the action is done for
its own sake because it's the right
thing to do this is why it's a de
ontological type of mathematics do you
guys all see that if you have a day out
two logical ethics you have to sooner or
later tell somebody what the duties
actually are and you have to express
them in some way this is one way to do
it it's very clear and at a certain
point it may be satisfying very
satisfying for your meny very
unsatisfying because you might be one of
the people who wants to know why should
I do things this way that leads us to a
different issue that so that's where
we're going to actually try to figure
out what is a categorical